in five four three two one konichiwa
[ __ ] welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast we have a an old
reoccurring guest from back in the day
from the original genius brain the one
that was in my condo
we have edrick also known as IDI - it's
been a minute I know dude I haven't seen
this dude in like five months going
through a world of depression I've been
locked up in a cave you know so I'm back
out now ready to embrace them during the
worst time they're in kovaydin
everything man what you've been up to
it's been crazy man it's been crazy I
mean like most people just been at home
you know trying to find things to do
because it's like where else girls can I
go what else can I do I've never seen so
many of my like friends from back in the
day yeah they they've been showing these
random what they call hidden talents
yeah aren't hidden talents because
they're not talents right I should have
stayed a long time how many of my
friends are suddenly rappers my [ __ ]
mind right yeah I've been working on
this project for a hot minute I'm like
did you come from yeah you're like doing
these shitty ass [ __ ] rhymes I'm like
oh like you never rap what you like this
new hot album that you're dropping out
of nowhere
Kobe making people go crazy dude yeah I
think I think it's just kind of like
they're taking the moment or the
situations again of like better than
better themselves and work on something
that's been long neglected because they
got the extra time now for me I just
kind of took it as a time to hit my
video game backlog yeah I know how much
a [ __ ] Nintendo switches right now
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy the the full
console is like six hundred bucks now
because it's selling out cuz Animal
Crossing everybody and their mom is on
animal cross dude - you know it was 300
bucks black ovid yeah and then I was
looking it up for 600 up to buy it for
my brother for his birthday just passed
happy birthday yeah birthday John but
then I saw it 600 bucks and I text that
falls I get you next time
[Laughter]
once a year right so we got another I
love you dude but you only six hundred
dollars I love you though
mean that the animal crossing phenomenon
is like ridiculous right now and have
you been playing that [ __ ] no I mean my
girl has it though so I did create my
character through her account but then
she's like you're not even playing so
what you off my she wanted me to delete
my character so she could have more
realistic Nintendo is so smart because
they develop games that everybody can
provide right it's not just for the
gamers not for the for the [ __ ]
Dungeons & Dragons eeks or your mom your
dad the kid the 20 year old the
businessman can all play it for sure
Animal Crossing kills it do know for
sure and the thing is it's like when you
look at kind of like the art direction
and aesthetics of the game it might look
childish but then the gameplay mechanics
right that's where it really kicks in
for all age groups like when you just
look at you like oh you know that that
looks like it's suited for you know
little kids elementary kids junior high
kids or whatever you start playing
you're like Yoda shits actually pretty
fun they know the best time because of
kovat in the social distance yeah yeah
they're socializing through a digital
world yeah and they're doing all the
stuff that they typically probably could
do if they were outside right be not
fish for [ __ ] great white sharks but
they're able to socialize with their
friends right the game they're visiting
each other's islands that game blew the
[ __ ] up there are certain industries
during Kobe that are killing it yeah
number one PS [ __ ] you Bowflex Bowflex
they're dumbbell went from $200 I'm
about 500 yeah they're gouging people
right now I can't wait til covitz gone
[ __ ] destroy your company you sons of
[ __ ]
unless you're short your stock Buffalo
Ida unless you want to sponsor me and
send me one dude we're bad terms dude I
try to get up [ __ ] both legs dumbbell
yeah and you're the you guys are the
reasons why I can't have muscles man
yeah no I mean it's create like the kind
of behavior that this pandemic is kind
of cultivated yeah it's wild man it's
wild like when when it first started
breaking out and the whole thing was
toilet papers running out mm-hmm I was
just kind of like I didn't understand
that I was
all right we're its deficit if we have
stay at home or cuz at the time stay at
home orders having kicked in yet
yeah and so I'm like if we're kind of
getting to the point where people are
gonna have to stay at home you're gonna
[ __ ] have running water still yeah I
mean what's the worst just [ __ ]
washer I know it's an inconvenience
people but you don't have to [ __ ]
toilet paper like it was blowing my mind
you nobody's doing the most Asian [ __ ]
right now
they don't even know people used to
[ __ ] wonder why we have the days then
why would you have a bidet why do you
want [ __ ] water see and now you can't
get a bidet anywhere you can't [ __ ]
anywhere you the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
has to clown on us about the mask and
now I see you with masks everywhere
quartermaster [ __ ]
you see a [ __ ] Louie Vuitton had like
a Louis Vuitton masking [ __ ] I mean it
was just a matter of time I was once the
mask started selling out I knew for them
sure like alright it's gonna get to the
point where we're gonna have designer
masks come out they're gonna charge an
arm and a leg and it's not even gonna be
a protective mask it's just gonna be a
piece of cloth yeah I head of um I was
telling people about this too where when
the whole coma thing happened and it was
about two months in yeah and I talked
about this on a podcast with my buddy
from Sacramento but I had probably three
instances of what people treated me like
[ __ ] just based on the fact that I was
agent yeah you know that's never ever
happened to me before
so no I'm I mean the one time somebody
called me a [ __ ] was this [ __ ] this
one black girl in my high school but
then she got [ __ ] suspended for that
[ __ ] like we had like a general
tolerance ship for racism you're right
but I don't know what she was going
through but that [ __ ] was hurtful I
didn't know what the [ __ ] she was called
me she was like you [ __ ] she's like
you [ __ ] just got me a [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] and like what's a [ __ ] I don't
know what a good was yeah I learned what
a [ __ ] was for the first time being
called that - yeah [ __ ] like how you
know what soup is called in Korean dude
but we when I you know stop you know
South Pasadena super nice condo that I
used to have been where we did the
original genius brain yeah like Kay and
I we do like [ __ ] 8 mile walks a day
that's just what we do and so we're
walking around and then
we noticed so there's this joint called
lawmen arca lawmen ARCA is the is a
Mexican like coffee shop right I have
like crunches they have like the rest
let just cakes and also stuff hello
hello and so we walk in there and we
were walking and we kind of knows this
lady with a fat ass and she she had a
kid or whatever right I was partially
the reasons why we're walking in there
and so we go in and you notice this lady
she's kind of dressed up very oddly she
has a visor on and everything else like
that and this lady with the fat ass and
the kid the kid kind of gets a little
close to the lady because he's looking
at some of the cookies yeah her
displayed yeah and then she freaks out
at the kid and she goes ma'am you need
to control your child and have him step
away from me no you need to have social
distancing like yelling at the lady the
lady was very calm about it okay fine
yeah well I'm sorry and she takes the
kid over and she looks at some cookies
yeah and so oh she also mentioned that
you need to be mindful of the the
labeling on the floor six oh yeah number
one this is when the social distancing
just happened I even noticed those
things right before before they weren't
there the day before because I was
literally in the store yesterday yeah so
she gets her cookies and she looks back
and the lady's waiting in line and she
looks at her she goes hey do you want me
to go around you or do you do you want
me to wait for you to go first and she
goes ma'am you need to back away from me
and she's yelling at her yeah so you
know this this seemingly white lady is
yelling at this lady she has like a she
has like a baby carriage and a stroller
and everything I'm like okay she's being
protected from her child or whatever and
she just keeps going off on her she goes
I'm a co-ed nurse and I'm dealing with
this stuff and you need to back away
from me and so at this point looks
leading lady's getting mad and she claps
back at her she goes that's funny cuz
I'm a nurse - yeah oh [ __ ] yelling at
each other being care like you know what
the [ __ ] is going on yeah and so at that
point that they when they were young age
had it eventually kind of simmered down
and the lady who was yelling at the lady
with the fat ass and the kid she has to
say one more word and she goes yours
you're usually you're acting like such a
[ __ ] yeah in front of a kid and then
Kay comes they should go he goes hey
lady a B word in front of her kid yeah
and I stepped it does again [ __ ]
[ __ ] you can find this [ __ ] kid you
[ __ ] know but I after she does that
she goes I didn't call her a [ __ ] I
called her a witch and I'm like wow like
that you called a [ __ ] in front of a
kid and so after that kind of simmers
down and then and then the manager is
telling everybody to calm down my order
gets called up I go up and I went to go
grab my coffee and then when two people
grab my coffee I was like I gotta say
something too and I was like you know
you're kind of out of line you shouldn't
be cursing at this lady in front of her
kid who's really disrespectful okay and
she goes you need to mind your [ __ ]
business and I was like oh and the crate
looks at me no [ __ ] prior to this day
before I reeled in another [ __ ] for
another incident so I I kind of already
let my steam out so this way I just
looked at I was like I don't wanna shut
the [ __ ] up yeah I'm gonna do something
about it Yeah right what do you do yeah
and so as she's doing that she goes you
know what it's it's like this problem
here is because of you people oh and the
fight oh [ __ ] she called me you people
that's my first you people I was like
damn dude and then before I could even
say anything the manager steps in and
she goes excuse me ma'am you people yeah
that is racist yeah right and she goes I
am NOT being racist I said you people as
in people who don't social distance she
goes we know what you mean and in my
mind I was like she could have meant
that yeah but I did not take it that way
right I was like you people yeah and so
as that whole situations happening this
is the funniest part the lady the the
white lady looks at the the manager who
was also a white lady or so I thought
and she goes I can't be racist she goes
because I'm Mexican and she goes my name
is something-something Esperanza blah
blah blah and then she starts speaking
was white and then the white man or she
goes well I'm Spanish I'm Mexican too
and then she starts thinking
these are yelling at each other in
Spanish and I'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
yeah and then I step in I'm like I am
also Spanish
Spanish as well and so they started
yelling at each other and [ __ ]
Spanish because they're both Mexican
apparently had no [ __ ] idea yeah and
the lady eventually gets kicked out but
as she's going out she goes you all of
you people are crazy and I started
feeling bad because I like maybe she's
being really protective of a child and I
look into the stroller it's three
Chihuahuas in there dude babied is one
of those though weirdest interactions
I've ever seen that's the first time I
was ever called you people yeah
literally call me you people down is you
crazy no but the thing is it's like you
know not even Chinese
you're [ __ ] and you people yeah it's
like you call me Luke nah but the thing
is it's like I think the the situation
with the pandemic is really putting
people on edge and and it's like kind of
taking the problems that already existed
in America and then really exaggerating
it yeah and it doesn't help when you
know the leaders of the country are
saying some things that can come across
races oh for sure it's emboldened people
who have those thoughts already before
it was like yeah those are private
thoughts yeah now it's like not only are
they public thoughts it's public speech
you know and I'm gonna make it known
that you [ __ ] chinks yeah that's your
China virus this is that your fault
right yeah it's really crazy to see so
it's like I don't get it man it's it's
it's like look man it's a problem that
the world is going through not just
America yeah you know so it's a bit
should be a time where everybody's
trying to support each other yeah and
and if anything try to band together but
like the exact opposite is happening
yeah it's it's really sad to see that
that's kind of what America has always
been you know it's not it just happened
it's it's that's what America has best a
lot of like for my personal experience
anyways and I know and I do want to
mention that this is like three
incidences of like 99 or a
why people being really nice to me okay
it's just like the bad stuff always
sticks out okay and I were also walking
one time and we were going on our normal
walk and this lady this all white lady
and there's always the [ __ ] old white
people because they're from a generation
where that [ __ ] was acceptable right so
this lady has a rake and in my mind is
pretty funny I mean I guess it's pretty
bad but you're kind of hilarious - yeah
because she's old what am I gonna do
slap the [ __ ] gun like dentures out
of her [ __ ] mouth so she has a rake
right and she's waking up her [ __ ]
leaves and she goes you he's like you
guys don't have a mess you need to stay
away from me and she starts doing this
oh right I'm like oh she might just it
must be because I don't know mask on I
get it you know she's being a little
cautious I'm like all right cool so we
keep walking there and then you know
Khalif is right behind me with with ray
yeah and then khalif's like you see that
[ __ ] I was like that's probably because
we even had the mask yeah yeah but you
know they had masks on right but they
said she kind of said it to them - what
am i interesting cool this this couple
walks by super close to her way closer
than we were we were like 12 feet away
and no mass not being as she goes good
morning [ __ ] races as home you know
the thing is I didn't have an experience
like that in terms of uh just kind of
like blatant racism but III did have
moments of like being at the store like
at the market and then you know just
non-asian people as soon as they see me
just kind of like back in like literally
having that kind of jerk back you know
like alright that's strange you know and
like I just want to [ __ ] in somebody's
mouth so bad that's what a [ __ ] on their
tonsils and Suns a business and then
like you know the first time it happened
I just I was just kind of that's a
little weird and then you know in the in
the same like shopping session it
happened about two more times and I'm
like okay there's some definitely there
yes probably because of them kind of
having you know these ideas of certain
ideas maybe I don't know if I'm gonna go
as far as saying racist but it could
just be ignorant too you know yeah I
mean I'm this close to just passing out
the middle of a supermarket just to
scare people okay woman's gonna fall
over and start crawling on my forearms
towards them like a [ __ ] zombie
just coughing every word you know what's
interesting you know because of the
whole covert situation you heard about
like the Ahmad Arbor II thing right No
so a Matar beret the kid who got killed
out in Georgia oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I guess that happened around the
same time that the whole Cogan situation
was happening yeah and so his story got
completely [ __ ] buried yeah and it
started resurging now because of footage
and a lot of people being outspoken
about it right and that whole situation
blew my [ __ ] mind good I didn't hear
about any of that yeah and usually when
it comes to you know racial [ __ ]
happening yeah especially specifically
with the media and you have phone
footage yeah that stuff gets blown up
like crazy right
and it took what from February all the
way till what what's now what may mm-hmm
February till May for people to finally
realize like for to finally come to
surface and prior to that if it wasn't
for the actual footage being taken like
recorded yeah I feel like it would have
just been slid right on in the fryi
table right like that whole story blows
my [ __ ] mind yeah did you see the
actual yeah I did I saw the footage of
like the truck chasing him when you hear
the [ __ ] clip load yep and it's like
dude this guy was just [ __ ] going for
a job man
yeah and like in athletic gear he was
like he was out for a jog and and and
the guy who who whose footage came to
light you know it came to light cuz he
thought that it was gonna help his
friends so you know that right I had no
[ __ ] idea so he thought like well
clean is yeah let me show y'all a little
something about a little black boy
running around and we got him and and
also he thought it would help his case
because his lawyer was basically saying
that I was in the car behind me yeah he
wasn't doing anything but you clearly
hear the gun and it's like well what
were you doing getting your gun ready
then right you guys were clearly chasing
this dude right and basically trying to
do so
thing and I don't know if they were
trying to kill him at the at the very
least try to scare him maybe but it just
escalated like that because the dude
probably got frightened too like of
course I wonder for [ __ ] I got like four
white dudes with guns chasing me I got
to defend myself
that [ __ ] was so hard to watch because
when you look at that footage yeah and I
say this not to exaggerate if I'm pretty
obviously everybody has seen this and
the reason why I haven't really talked
about it is because I wanted to see some
some [ __ ] come out about this done
because every time I see this in the
media and everybody has their own
opinions about this but when somebody
gets murdered specifically a person of
color yeah yeah what I see a lot too is
other people looking up dirt on this kid
to see and what are they doing what the
[ __ ] are you trying to prove they're
like okay well well did you know that he
used to [ __ ] smoke weed who the [ __ ]
cares yeah I think I smoke weed all the
time see what the [ __ ] does that mean
does that mean he's automatically a
criminal I don't know that sounds really
rudimentary like a very rudimentary
argument to say but if you don't know
what that feels like it's hard to
explain what what how terrible that how
terrible that situation is right right
so like if you look at that footage and
if you haven't seen that footage yet you
probably live under a rock and if you do
take the time to look at it because I
want you to see a video of a kid being
hunted down like he was a wild boar like
I've seen videos of like people in
Hawaii hunt boar like in you know yeah
yeah that's what that [ __ ] looked like
it looks like they were hunting wild
game right and it blew my [ __ ] mind
number one just if you guys look up know
I've been reading up a lot about this
you can you can hear the dispatcher call
right in the dispatch an dispatcher I
don't know if that's the right term but
the dispatch right and I'm paraphrasing
this but basically he goes I see there's
a there's a black man running in the
neighborhood and they go okay what is he
doing he goes he's running is he
breaking any laws is he doing anything
that night they robbed the house it's
really silent because he's not doing
anything well there's been breakings and
around the neighborhood and they're like
okay but what is he doing did he did you
see him do anything yeah and he just
gets DET radio silent right cuz he
doesn't he doesn't have anything to say
yeah and then he decides to take the law
into his own hands which is for some
[ __ ] reason that's like a white
person thing you know to put it in
perspective in Sacramento there was a
situation too with an
young man who was murdered and there was
a kid in Sacramento my best friend told
me this in Sacramento they said he said
something very profound and I might be
slaughtering this but he says he said he
kind of what he said was you know for
the white people that are listening to
this and this is like in Sacramento City
the capital yeah and he said what it
feels like if you're not a person of
color for white people to be a colored
person in this country it feels like I
am a guest in my own home right right
and you guys are the house owner all
right no matter what I do I'm told that
I have to be on my best behavior
don't put your shoes here don't do this
and that yeah and then I have to be on
my best behavior when this is my house -
right but I feel like I'm put out as a
guest and that's what it feels like to
be a person of color in this country
right for example it's like how many
times have you have you seen in
Sacramento where somebody goes out and
you see a bunch of kids like black kids
they're playing music it's just their
music and somebody rolls up them in a
car says put that music down mm-hmm why
yeah why yeah this is their country -
yeah it's just music but because you see
these group of black people you have to
tell them how to behave within your
society because this is the proper way
to do it because this is how you see fit
right and a lot of people may may may
disagree with this and I'm not like
trying to put on white guilt but when
people talk about white privilege
yeah the the counterpart to to what
people say about that they talk they try
to bring in statistics right right well
statistically statistically this this
and that people you know you know black
Americans Asian Americans they have this
amount of opportunities for jobs this
and that but we're talking about when it
comes to white privilege or when I feel
like that right it's it's that idea that
thing kids talking about so I feeling
like I'm a guest in somebody else's
house think if I don't behave
accordingly yeah then I'm not following
the rules then that kind of categorizes
me as the right American right person
who set those rules are white people
right and so we always feel this way
yeah right it's it's that underlying
tone that people don't know that they
have yes it's almost like I am the
enforcer and it's my job as a person who
was not of color to let you know that
this is how you should behave in this
country right no I mean you look at kind
of history too and even kind of the
Asian population japanese-americans
right I mean they were called the model
minorities but the honorary White's
yeah like you're not you're not a just a
responsible citizen you're like us Yeah
right possible yes responsibility being
an up prices and is something that's an
attribute of us right and now you're
more like right right and so it's it's
the whole irony of it the whole damn
thing man is that we're all visitors
here in America is a land of immigrants
yeah we stole this land from Native
Americans it's not we why people do okay
we did it we built the railroads here we
laid the infrastructure Logan do your
taxes I mean that's that's the the irony
of it all man is that it's a land of
immigrants but at some point in history
you know it just became yeah this is our
[ __ ] land and you guys are all
visiting here you know and it's uh it's
crazy to me man it's really crazy to me
that in 2020 I mean I don't I can't
throw out a percentage of like what
percentage of the country of people
actually are like this but if I had to
guess I would say at least like twenty
to thirty percent yeah you know I mean
because outside of places like
California you know New York right Texas
what I mean some parts of Texas
you have rural America you know yeah and
in rural America again I don't I don't
know if I could go as far as saying
these people are outright racist but at
the least ignorance plays a part in in
kind of the world view you know did you
see a photo of those [ __ ] -
they look like they [ __ ] each other's
cousins all the time dude the dad
apparently was a former police officer
really yeah so the dad was a former
police officer and the reason why the
this thing kept on getting pushed
further and further was because I I
don't want to use the the the improper
term but basically the people who are
supposed to be involved in the case or
who were supposed to persecute him or
whatever where the judge or something
else yeah they had a personal interest
with them because maybe the work with
him
or something else so they kept on
recusing themselves from the from the
case over and over and over and they
wouldn't make the arrests so that's
that's why they were so he thought he
was he thought he was [ __ ] Judge
Dredd this [ __ ] hillbilly he was
Judge Dredd so he literally thought he
was [ __ ] Sylvester Stallone Judge
Dredd a pot-bellied hillbilly and he
took matters into his own hand I
actually read a comment from somebody to
which he didn't infuriate me now I think
when I was younger if I read a comment
like that I would get really upset yeah
but it kind of just goes to show how
when we see these specific cases instead
of looking at the tragedy and looking at
how terrible the situation somebody lost
their life yeah we try to justify that
person's death by fighting bad things
right right you disparage their
character exactly and so so what
somebody wrote on my comment and I
blocked this person to just because of
how insensitive and stupid this person
is and they write it was like well he
well he should have been smarter he
shouldn't have went to grab the gun he
would have still been alive and I'm like
you don't know what it's like to be in
that situation right the guy's being
hunted right I would freak out I don't
know what I would have done I might have
ran I might have grabbed for the gun
yeah but it's what do you how do you
know what it feels like to be hunted
down just for jogging it's a fight or
flight exactly I don't know that point
right I mean you're gonna react in a way
that you usually don't react when your
life when you feel like your life is
being threatened yeah let me talk a lot
listen I talk a lot of [ __ ] too man like
when if you put me in a scenario like if
edrick right now ask me goes yo somebody
comes up you and slaps you in the face
what are you gonna do most likely I'd
say I'd [ __ ] them up but I'm not
accounting if this man is like a six
foot eight right Armenian bodybuilder
that came bro he pulls out a gun right
after he does I just got slats the whole
story yeah he's like what happened what
would you do I would be like what the
[ __ ] he would slap me I'd be like all
right and I would move on we don't know
what we're like until he's situations
like case in point yeah one time I saw
his Jamba Juice in South Pasadena and I
literally saw somebody get mugged right
in front of the Jamba Juice huh and in
my mind I walked up and I was like hey
stop and I stopped this person in real
life I had my mouth open and I watched
the guy get robbed and I watch the eye
in my mind I assume that I stopped him
but he just got robbed and he looked at
me goes what happened I'm like no cuz
sometimes it's such a I guess it's so
far from reality of like everyday things
that you see that it might kind of stun
you too you know yeah and almost
paralyze you because you're just you're
trying to really internalize what it is
that you just saw you're just trying to
digest what you saw I think it's quite
called like like normalcy bias or some
it's like something like that and where
it's when these situations happen that
are out of the norm yeah your brain
tries to process it in the normal stuff
that you typically see like you don't
see that happen then in front of you
right right you can't really process it
so what happens is you sit there with
your [ __ ] mouth open waiting for
flies to come in yeah and that's what
happened to me yeah I saw that do get
mug and I didn't know what was going on
or what was happening yeah so you know
we even hear about that in certain like
psychological findings where they wasn't
the bystander effect where somebody was
getting murdered in the alleyway yeah
everybody expected somebody else to call
the writer but he did any right right so
there's a lot of these random
assumptions and you don't really know to
say to say that a mod shouldn't have
jumped for the gun it's like you don't
know what it's like to be in that
situation I think the point the story is
and when you look at this and you could
go ahead and be an inquisitive person
and try to find the facts of what
actually happened yeah but you know tis
to sit there and try to find facts and
disparage this character of this human
being who just lost his life when you
look at the footage he was literally
just jogging and let's just say let's
just say he was on and they later on CNN
I was reading an article the neighbor
released the footage of people who came
to that house I guess a mod once looked
into the they walked in towards the
house
whatever he didn't walk in the house it
was looking at the construction site
yeah but so we're children yeah so were
other people there was like 11 or 12
people yeah and that was it yeah so
there was no reason for anybody to think
that he was the one that was out there
like breaking into a house he wasn't
right that what about the other 11
people are the children maybe should
have shot that [ __ ] little kid that
little five-year-old that came into the
house right murder that child too they I
don't know but you know they they try to
find stuff to kind of justify their hate
and that's the problem that I have is a
huge issue that I have oh for sure for
sure man I mean it's like it's if it's
not already bad in
that you know human being has lost their
life like you said they trying to find
reasons and throwing against the wall to
see what sticks yeah like yeah it was
just a fight though you know this guy
deserved to die right for for these
reasons and usually those reasons are
just it's like what do you what the [ __ ]
are you talking about man how come y'all
can't just mind your [ __ ] business
too
why is it so hard to mind your business
let me tell you some mind your business
is one of the best things you could ever
do in your life it makes it makes life
so much easier like I said I saw
somebody get robbed at Jamba Juice and I
said mind your business I mean I just
don't understand like where this
deep-rooted hate for a group of people
stems from like that i I just don't get
that man yeah I mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of weird III I really wish
I wanted to talk to people about this
too especially people in another country
right because there's there's uh there's
like people who immigrated from Africa
to other countries to I wonder if they
have that same level of disdain towards
you know for us African Americans are
lazy when their countries were Afro
Europeans or whatever right I wonder
because the African American situation
is way different right because from us
we started from slavery yeah right they
were literally considered less than
human beings yeah and then through the
Civil War they gained their rights
yeah and after that there's just whole
and this is a whole other talk to you
about like systemic oppression how no
matter how many times like and there's
somebody of like after an African
American descent tries to come up
there's always something set in place to
push them down and they just have to
work that much harder to be in a place
of success yeah right so our our country
is rooted in in a lot of evil [ __ ] yeah
yeah right it's just you know healing
from that and moving past that I think
it takes a lot more than we think it
does right is it's easy just to say as
an individual like okay well I'm not
racist which is fine right I think that
we are we should only to a certain
percent be held accountable for the
stuff that we do yeah but to deny that
some that this country feels a certain
way
about people of color is also not doing
anybody anything good either right you
know it's it's hard cuz like I don't
like white guilt I mean white guilts a
little odd yeah I understand it I think
it's great to understand what happens in
the privilege that you get from being a
white American yeah it's cool yeah but I
think I get really weirded out sometimes
when they really want to let you know
how guilty or you know like hey man dude
I bought a bottle of kimchi today and
whoa I eat every day probiotics I love
Korean barbeque by the way it's who
doesn't like meat and vegetables right
exactly exactly I always find a little
annoying when uh yeah I get told that
it's like oh you're Korean I love Korean
barbecue yeah like what why did you find
a need to just you know express that
yeah oh you're why I love Stouffer's
stovetop stuffing
yes [ __ ] amazing it's the best thing
I've ever had in my life i hydrated with
water and I baked inside a turkey but
it's great it's [ __ ] delicious
no but yeah I don't know man I I just
don't know like why that that kind of
hate has endeared so long for these
group of people but you know it just
kind of goes to like the argument of gun
violence to write is like should we have
more guns in this country or should we
have less guns in this country and
that's that's really a big issue and
also let me say where is the NRA
when when you know about this issue
right when when a black man is murdered
yeah there's the NRA about you know
maybe they did say something not even
really look into that it's funny you
mentioned that whole gun issue thing
where I was talking about with a friend
of mine you know her but she I was
talking about how I I want a gun again
right so the last time I had a gun it
was a legal gun I got from one of the
homies yeah but I never owned a legal
firearm I'm an adult now I'm not gonna
get a [ __ ] a legal firearm yeah and
she was like I can't believe you're
gonna get a gun and I'm like why why why
can't why can't you believe that [ __ ]
and she goes
well what do you could seriously take
the life of somebody I was like if they
enter my home and they're trying to
[ __ ] kill me yeah I kill them like
I'm a North Korean did here I would
[ __ ] blast them on sight yeah of
course I would if she goes I can't
believe you would do that she goes you
don't need a gun and I was like you know
kind of what I what I said to her was
like that's so interesting I was like
but you have to realize how you grew up
and how I grew up to like you always
grew up in a very very pretty like
you're a rich person you had money grow
right you never lived in a neighborhood
where these things don't happen even now
though the neighborhood live is a little
nicer
I still like on the border of ghetto and
not right and there was a robbery that
happened right around the [ __ ] corner
yeah somebody got its shot up like
Highland Park is right around the corner
somebody got shot up recently over there
like these things do happen we can't
deny that break-ins don't happen to
other people do have guns I'm not saying
I'm gonna walk around and shoot people
right right but I do enjoy the fact that
I do feel more protected if I do have a
firearm on me but in her in her world
because she doesn't live in that she
never has the concept that somebody can
rob you and I take your [ __ ] yeah it's
though she understands it she doesn't
understand it too like uh like a
molecular right it was never a real
situation for her it's just a
hypothetical yeah like I don't even
people understand that you have any idea
how frightening it is to have a gun
pointed at you it's like the most
scariest [ __ ] feeling on earth I've
had a gun pointed at me twice in my life
and the last time I did I almost [ __ ]
myself like a little [ __ ] came out this
was when I was 18 that's the last time I
had a gun pointed at me yeah and that
[ __ ] [ __ ] scared me yeah and through
whatever grace of god I did it [ __ ]
die thank [ __ ] god yeah but that fear
has always stuck with me it's like oh
[ __ ] I could have [ __ ] died right and
I guess like the counter-argument to
that is like well because guns are legal
he had a gun at you [ __ ] and
that guy's gun wasn't legal the [ __ ]
North Daniels gun is not legal
whatsoever yeah no no no for sure I mean
like if that situation has never been
real to somebody it's hard to wrap their
head around that you know of why you
would need a gun why would you possibly
need a gun right
because you I live in a nice gated
neighborhood and I don't ever see a
reason why a gun would be needed I have
to start patrolling 24/7
yeah then if that's the case you
probably don't need one you know but
people who have or different upbringings
came from different backgrounds and
different experiences they might beg to
differ you know they might feel a
certain type of security with a firearm
you know you know what the the like be a
mod Arbor II case to like I I kind of
wrote this on a post to where I was kind
of putting in a perspective of you know
because the whole Coby thing we'd be
seeing a lot of these videos and yeah
people [ __ ] up like a lot of older
Asian people yeah yeah yeah it's really
hard to watch right because we picture
our parents and those two exactly man
it's so infuriating one and you don't
see these videos have been happening to
like strong able body that don't rise
older women and that's the part that
really pisses me off is that you should
pick on somebody you should do that to a
[ __ ] Asian boy right like hop sing or
watching cameras listen you do to that
right but you're not gonna [ __ ] do it
cuz I [ __ ] like clapped on site right
that's it yeah but you know the thing
that I wanted other people to kind of
take away from that too and I think I
also read a lot of comments to where
people kind of they kind of they also
Asian people sometimes don't understand
what other cultures go through because
you know we have our own [ __ ] though
yeah absolutely but for anybody who's
been calling you people or you've
experienced these moments of racism
that's been happening you know it's it
sucks for us too it's really bad yeah
but that's just kind of like a glimpse
of what black Americans go through right
right right
like it's it's just to put it in
perspective so I think it's it's a
learning lesson too and the only
positive thing that I could think of
that is like now we have group of people
who never felt that empathy if you if
you're crying out for justice for for
your race in your culture
you're doing it for another person's
culture also speaks for yours too now
right so like for me I'm like hey
remember that time where you said that
you know that that young black man what
the [ __ ] was he doing I was like what
was that agent doing the Asian lady
doing out there when she was on that bus
stop where are you gonna find some some
terrible or disparaging facts about that
person to justify why she got here
you're not gonna do that right you know
that's just to go and show you how
different it is yeah yeah yeah not for
sure for sure I mean the thing is it's
like in a perfect world we'll have
justice you know it will have equal
justice right just err just don't that's
don't straight up dude Jesus dialed in
God is Grace and also pain I mean but
you know the thing is like we don't live
in a perfect world and unfortunately we
don't have that I guess that type of
justice that yeah we might want for for
some of these cases and it's like at the
very least you might I mean at least
technology is there to kind of bring it
to the forefront make it a little bit
more visible putting on people's faces
have people at the very least talk about
it to you know have a conversation swear
it starts from right you got to start
having a conversation about these issues
easier to not even think about it when
you're not even aware that these issues
exist right but you bring it to the
forefront put it in people's faces
people sharing it on social media and I
guess that's one good thing in social
media I mean for the most part I really
dislike social media especially more so
during the pandemic yeah but it's also
good for those type of cases you know to
bring like social justice issues to the
forefront and have people talk about it
yeah especially young people in the
country in the world right and you know
honestly like we have these first world
problems here in America I mean I'm not
talking about like the deaths of
minorities and categorizing that as now
I'm saying you know more trivial stuff
right and then you look at the some of
the other countries in the world this
stuff that they're going to and you're
like man we're complaining about not
being able to get a haircut it's like
kids are fearing for their life yo man
Dave Chappelle said this [ __ ] the best
right he says like people have some of
the most brittle spirits in this country
there's so little man Dave Chappelle is
also talking about me sometimes I'm
brittle this fun right right
yeah I trust me I'm with everybody when
I does I get irritated where I you know
when when this whole [ __ ] started
happening and then I started reading
post yeah about like you know if you if
you was talking about the reason why you
couldn't go out there and do this
because you didn't have time and you're
not honing your craft or in quarantine
then you was never you never wanted in
the first place shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
how about that [ __ ] jacking off watching
all I got is to spend my [ __ ]
quarantine like I get it and you know
it's yeah it's it's weird sometimes when
we we complain about all these like
small little things like I just like I
had these moments now like because of
quarantine where I said I'm very
grateful for the things that I have like
yeah your [ __ ] car yeah even like
something small like that and it's to
put it in a perspective once again not
not to bring money up in this all the
time but you know for people who grew up
with a lot of [ __ ] and I tend to get
along with people who didn't grow up
with a lot of [ __ ] has been kind of have
a similar foundation yeah yeah it's hard
to explain to people how to be grateful
for things that you didn't have growing
up yeah it's a different [ __ ] oh
absolutely man absolutely I mean that's
that's why for me it's easier for me
it's like during this time to really
appreciate what I have you know I'm
gonna be honest with you bro like what
makes me feel fulfilled and happy is
like filling up my car having a full
tank so having a having groceries in my
fridge yeah that rip genuinely makes me
feel like fulfilled and happy yeah
and it's because growing up I wasn't
able to just get whatever I wanted I can
just oh I want some [ __ ] Lunchables
let me throw anything I want some pop no
it's like alright you could pick one you
know out of a hundred dude a lot of
people don't understand yeah they don't
they don't get that type of struggle
yeah yeah for us it was a rate everyday
occurrence so it doesn't seem like a
much much of a struggle to us as a kid
because our parents never had to make us
feel that we were less because we didn't
have them write write write anything
that's the the the great thing that a
lot of like good parents do and no
matter how poor you are you make sure
that your kids never feel poor yeah yeah
they let you know that you're poor but
they don't make sure that you know that
you should be grateful for every
rich in love guys yeah because I
remember when we went to the grocery
store it's like I want this and that
it's like you get one maybe yeah how are
your grades last you know quarter or you
know exactly like you get all eight part
of it was because we were [ __ ] the
other part was because they couldn't
afford it so when I have a car
I even today I was sitting like when you
before you came here I was sitting in
the trunk is it nice yeah I get to sit
in the [ __ ] trunk of my car
yeah and chill right this feels [ __ ]
right good yeah and that that food thing
right so people people don't understand
the luxury of even having the option of
choosing different types of food a day
when I was a kid man every Sunday my mom
made a big pot of something and then I
had to do something with that leftover
and make something new out of it right
so if my mama came to get ya I'm a pop
and then sometimes I made like fried
rice with it and this has hella
different iterations ah yeah but that
wasn't the main dish and then we did
what we cook with it yeah right that's
the thing it's like like you said man
people don't get it if they haven't been
in that situation what that where that
stems from you know and it's like it's
like look I'm not saying you have to
adopt my mindset or or try to be like me
but understand where it's coming from
laughs these this is the way I grew up
yeah and it shaped me as a person and as
an adult you know it's not to knock
other people of like but I'm not gonna
lie man sometimes I'm like this [ __ ]
that people are complaining about them I
can't they'll [ __ ] out of here man oh
yeah do you have a roof over your head
you have clothes on your back do you got
food in your fridge you know John be
[ __ ] thing exactly the be [ __ ]
thankful man is right now what I think
15% of America are unemployed 20% I
don't know yeah and like a lot of people
don't have [ __ ] jobs right now and you
know what I don't have anybody in my
inner circle where any of anybody got
the virus but I do know people in my
inner circle where the pandemic has
affected them in terms of losing their
jobs things like that right a buddy of
mine AJ Rafael his cousin and his uncle
both passed away from holy [ __ ] yes
father and daughter passed away from
Coby that's crazy you know with with the
whole Kovac situation - yes you know
there's a lot of data coming out about
how I guess it's not as crazy as thought
and they thought it would be right
because they said that half of
California will be affected with kovat
and yeah your stuff so these stats
aren't true anymore
yeah and I understand that we're trying
to find a great balance and a medium to
make this thing work do I agree with
Governor Newsome ya know that we should
be quarantined till August
abso-fucking-lutely not because people
are there okay there yeah there's people
who have passed away obviously the
percentages are really [ __ ] small but
also - there's also people suffering
from losing their jobs and you're not
having to be able to make ends meet not
being able to pay rent yeah
so there you can't go and extreme here
and extreme here and expect people to be
happy there has to be something like you
know when they talk about opening up in
phases they didn't do a good job or he
didn't do a good job by saying hey by
the way three months you're [ __ ] yeah
he should have done it in phase it's
saying like hey instead of saying that
he goes hey we're actually going into
Phase one this week and then this month
and then the next month we'll be going
into Phase two or something like that
rather than is just telling people hey
three months you're [ __ ]
it was a very very poor plan to tell
people in LA that yeah I mean the thing
is it's like it's such a complicated
thing because first of all we weren't
ready for it yeah you know people at the
top didn't prepare for it as as well as
they could have especially considering
that we had about two months seeing what
was going on in other parts of the world
- to start preparing for it and so from
that standpoint I can understand like
they these people are trying their best
in a sense to figure out because they
don't know what they're doing right
exactly none of us nobody knows what the
folks like this is brand-new territory
and it's like it's such a complicated
issue because on one end like you said
people are dying people are getting sick
on the other end people are losing their
jobs and they're willing to even
risk getting sick and risk dying to stay
working right because they got to
provide for themselves and/or their
families right they got to eat they got
to pay rent all of that and then so like
considering the fact that the average
American in this country is in debt what
$10,000 I think that's the average
statistic right type yes yeah it man
imagine being behind three months and so
all right first of all you don't even
have savings right um and you're on
you're in debt on top of that right so
even with this stimulus stuff going on
you get a $1,200 check what the [ __ ] is
that gonna buy you yeah you know it's
gonna pay for what your rent yeah how is
it what's it gonna do for you right and
and I'm speaking for the people who
really literally live paycheck to
paycheck and so there's a lot of people
like that but ya know I think a majority
of Americans like that most of America's
like that over fifty percent I would
assume is like that and so you know we
started this conversation on a race
issue and and how I was saying that this
pandemic kind of exaggerated that put it
under a magnifying glass but all the
kind of the woes of America have been
put under a magnifying glass yeah
because of this pandemic right and so
like all the debt that this country has
the average citizen has in this country
minimum wage not being enough to
maintain basic quality of life right now
yeah it's like three months without a
paycheck
what the [ __ ] are they gonna do right
you know not only the fact that if they
come back three months behind they're in
a deeper hole than they were before you
know but the company or the person that
they were working for if their business
even survived in that three months
because that business could easily
closed down yeah without having revenue
for three months and just having money
going out right here's the interesting
to anything to where people kind of you
know people are making comparisons to
how the United States handle this yeah
and you know they're making other
comparisons to like Sweden to Korea
Japan and all that other stuff yeah
just from what I've read though if we if
we want results like Korea
you with the loose and very lacks way
that America has been with the whole
kovat pandemic thing yeah and even with
how relaxed they are with the with the
with what most people would with what
most people think are just really strict
rules here yeah it's not even
comparatively your any idea how lacks
our laws are compared to holidays like
in Korea yeah so somebody was making a
comparison that I was having a
conversation with he goes well look at
Korea they did it in like two months do
you know how they did it though you guys
are complaining right now in the states
when we're just not we're not allowed to
go to beaches and parks like legit if
you walk if you even have Kovac by the
way if you you have like basically a
tracer in your phone you're supposed to
pick up the phone like two to three
times a day if you don't pick up a phone
two to three times a day a government
agencies mages Aden goes to your house
right so you have a legit tracer on you
right they do multiple tests on you they
check to see if you're okay they see
where you're at and they make sure that
your quarantine inside your house period
and the story you want to go outside to
get some cigarettes or whatever even if
you're asymptomatic
you're not going [ __ ] anywhere that's
the stuff that they did to make sure
that they had the whole Cobra situation
in check yeah now if you're willing to
do that to as an American you're willing
to do that for about two months which by
the way people were freaking out at the
month mark yeah and even when the
government said you're not supposed to
do this and that we did it anyways and
and what happened yeah we didn't get a
tracer on our phone we have like a
[ __ ] ankle or anything else like yeah
and those are the things that you have
to forgo in order to get it in check
like that yeah but with the brittle
American spirit even when we have this
simple lockdown right the first is two
three a month
they lost their [ __ ] mind yeah I
guarantee you you guys talk really big
but if you if the government said hey we
need to have access to your phone and we
need to have a tracer on it to make sure
that you don't go anywhere and the
government's gonna call you two to three
times a day to make sure that you stay
in your house you're not gonna be like
okay so let's be realistic here right
which is so ironic because it's like man
all these [ __ ] people on tick tock do
you guys know what type of information
you're give
away look into that oh when I sigh oh
yeah what it what I beg Li looked into
this but I heard it's a lot it's all
right first I deleted my tick-tock
immediately yeah it's it's uh it's a
Chinese own app and they're basically
original virus yeah no I mean they're
collecting every bit of information on
you people don't know that though
because you guys are [ __ ] you
know it's the famous hungry
you know and tick tock famous hungry man
the amount of information that people
willingly give away without even [ __ ]
knowing with the apps that they have
right but then as soon as they feel like
oh this is infringing on my rights right
the Hopman arms right yeah and it's like
it's just the nature of America man it's
like first world problems
you know tic TOCs a very interesting app
and what I learned specifically from my
buddy David he has a hat that he's
putting out called taco app that's
opposed to his David Choi so David
choice grain thing about taco labs that
he wants to allow creators to take part
in the the money-making okay I think I
think I saw a Facebook post about that
yeah yeah so you know David really you
know for him starting off as a creator
he started to realize like yo these
companies are making a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah specifically companies like YouTube
and they do like Google Adsense where
you get this minimum amount of share and
there's even companies like tik-tok
which I do believe for if you know
they're that platform is made for people
to expand their business if you're
getting something out of it that's cool
depending on like the information that
you're giving out which I don't really
know too much about it yeah but
tik-tok they were like I forgot how many
billions of dollars they made in their
first like fiscal year yeah and then
creators made zero yeah I mean zero
[ __ ] dollars billions of dollars and
then you made zero dollars of it just
because you wanted to be known for the
guy who did really fast burger recipes
on tik-tok and I I don't even I don't
even know how tik-tok kind of shot up to
the the level it's at right now because
I remember when the app first came out I
was like what the [ __ ] is this thing
supposed to be I don't I don't
understand what the purpose of this
thing is it was like four I think it
popped off because of dancers it was it
was made for its tick-tock the reason
why tick tock does so well is because
it's a creative platform that does
I'll rely on you being an actual creator
so they have stuff in there to allow you
to create viral content without you
having to know how to do Photoshop or or
like Adobe Premiere or yeah like that
all that stuff is already integrated and
built out in there and they already have
popular trending stuff for you to follow
so they encourage that [ __ ] so for you
to pop off on Tech Talk is way easier
yeah
the only difference is what the tic-tock
app is that you can't even let's say one
video pops off at your necks it's not
guaranteed that your next video will get
similar views because they just see that
one video and move on they're not gonna
really follow you or wait for you to put
another video so for a few people who
already instafamous you know yeah I mean
the thing is at the end of the day
whatever you want to call tick-tock it's
a data miner you know yeah it's a data
miner masked as a social platform right
they get everything huh everything man
and the thing is data is king man data
is power right and so I could the
Chinese government is collecting all of
this [ __ ] on American citizens right and
what they can do with that data is very
powerful because they're they're able to
track your interests they able to track
your movement so they're able to predict
behavior uh-huh why do you think Amazon
is at the level that they are now
because they collected data these
bloodsuckers have taken so much money
from me in the last five pretty much you
know why man dog don't you speaking of
that [ __ ] you have any idea how many
times I book Martian on Instagram with
those ads and uh they know everything I
think they're listening I can listen I
said I said waist trainer once yeah
right I have a six waist trainer has
hybri what the [ __ ] do I need a waist
trainer for you sons of [ __ ] exactly
and that's what I'm saying is that you
are willingly giving away this
information you you're you're allowing
the permissions those permissions that
you don't read right it's more of a case
on iOS because on Android yeah at least
see the list of permissions you have to
allow on iOS the App Store you already
agree to it
I almost bought a Serbian knife
yesterday like a clear
and then it was on sale for $79 and I
was like bro I could use a serbian knife
fade and then I met Muriel was like you
have eight knives what the [ __ ] do you
need a Serbian knife for are they are
you right it was like yo Instagram
almost got my spot a Serbian knife yeah
I almost bought a portable fireplace but
I had no place to put yeah and then I
actually bought three boots which it was
actually a good investment I've been
looking for some good boots and but this
is other this company that I bought from
an Instagram and I I've mentioned before
verbally they're listening for sure dude
I've had many cases where I've said
something verbally not searched in it
through my phone at all yeah pops up
Instagram yeah yeah it does but that's
it's it's crazy man like I I watched a
documentary recently it's called the the
risin reign of Jeff Bezos right it's a
it's a documentary on Instagram by I
think by PBS anybody interested in that
type of subject matter you guys should
check it out but yes it's it's something
that I've known about data collecting
for a long time of how powerful data is
I just didn't realize to the extent that
like Amazon how much data they collected
on customers and one of their executives
were saying like what once Amazon
started to really take shape like once
it started moving beyond books how
surprised he was at how predictable
consumers are you know based on that the
data that they were collecting really
yeah yeah and so like that's why they're
able to sell you on this [ __ ] man
because they already know what your
interests are like that's the that's the
point we're at now where we've just
become predictable to an algorithm and
the algorithm just keeps on getting fed
information Alexa right it's a listening
device it's not a [ __ ] personal
assistant this thing is listening to you
right and in like that's why X Amazon
executives are talking about yeah I turn
and LexA off when I need to have
important conversations or conversations
that I
want to keep private I stopped using my
Alexa but I use a Google home though
hey Google was the original Data Miner
right there the original data collectors
that's how they're able to predict your
searches oh yeah but Google home helps
me wake up I mean I love this [ __ ] the
thing I use for the Google home all the
time is Google hey Google play the play
the sound of a beautiful rain forest
that's what I do every night or play the
sound of a of a rolling fire and I know
but like listen I don't get me wrong man
a lot of these things a lot of this
technology does make life a lot more
convenient for people but the point I'm
making is just know what you're signing
up for right it's like don't get so mad
about when when you have to share your
data knowingly when you're unknowingly
doing it already it's like on so many
different apps and things that you use
are the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] that I saw
was on Facebook when people are like I
hereby declare [ __ ] Facebook is not
allowed to use my private information
blah blah blah too late [ __ ] it's too
late and first of all whoo that's not
that that that was like a hoax radio
well chain mail types yeah no yeah I was
like the first of all you [ __ ] number
one yeah how who do you think you are
you are not that important I'm pretty
sure Facebook has collected your data
they printed it out on pieces of papers
and they burned it because that's how
useless you are dude there are people to
who who are so [ __ ] broke they they
would go to the liquor store and they
would hide their ATM number I might
listen I don't want the 12 skittles in
the bank okay broke [ __ ] what ATM
number are you hiding for like you know
do you have Harry Potter's [ __ ] safe
like the code 2 is safe you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you ain't got that type of money
yeah like it's so dumb but you know when
people were putting that [ __ ] up I was
like Doug know who you are as a person
nothing you say is ever important and
the government if they're listening to
you they probably already shot
themselves in the face because I've done
it but that's that's kind of like the
age that we live in - man the
information age no misinformation H to
be more accurate because like people
just think oh it's written it must be
true right cuz
look man we grew up in a time where if
we saw something that was written mm-hmm
very very high chance that it's true its
most likely it's like an editorial piece
or it's in a you know magazine or you
know there would be opinion pieces too
but nowadays it's like anybody could
create a site to look legitimate right
and then people share these articles
people share these pieces and it's like
sometimes so many times you have no yeah
they people don't do like the most basic
form of due diligence like I the
craziest [ __ ] to me is like when people
share these articles and and then pass
it off as fact when you [ __ ] click
the article itself and go down scroll to
the bottom it says we are what do you
call that a parody yeah a parody a site
right now parody news cycle onion or
some [ __ ] yeah leave something like the
onion right I'm like dude it literally
would have taken you two three seconds
to fact-check this right to see that
this is not true but so much
misinformation gets spread now it's
about being first you know that's the
crazy [ __ ] it's thinking [ __ ] about
being first I give a [ __ ] about being
right you know hope look at YouTube men
that one of the top comments that's been
going on for the past 12 years since
YouTube has been around isn't first yeah
first yeah people love being first then
rather being right and I get I get it to
a certain extent you know certain people
like if we're making jokes about stuff
it's it's kind of fly formed around
satire and and hypotheses right so
you're making just hypotheticals yeah
yeah which is fun to play around right
but when you put things out as facts and
you know people get hyped up and they
can't get caught up in things without
knowing the situation yeah that's the
stuff that I even I've fallen for right
but now I'm getting a little smarter
about it because like even talking about
like the amount Harbury case right
people are saying like yo you should do
this stuff right now and I'm like hold
on I got a sin think about this for
right right because it's not it's not so
easy for me to go ahead and bring it up
on a podcast and just talk about that
because number one I'm already
emotionally invested and more held up
yeah so I have to really sit down and
think about these thoughts yeah about
what happened yeah right I'm not looking
to just to vilify this kid first to find
out facts I could give a [ __ ] lesson
this kid smoked weed yeah I don't know
if I got into [ __ ] fistfights in high
school or whatever that doesn't matter
this kid was just jogging he got killed
didn't matter about his personal past or
whatnot right that very [ __ ] moment
he was killed because he was a black kid
running in a neighborhood that's it
period in the story I don't want to hear
[ __ ] right so I just made it a point not
to just jump on it because I've have
fallen into that habit of just wanting
to you know grab sensational topics and
just talk about it first promotional
responses right yeah you know I get
caught up in that [ __ ] and when I saw
that video of that of that Asian lady
getting kicked in the [ __ ] rice I
wanted to say some [ __ ] about that I'm
sure for sure that that that infuriated
me so much man I mean Bullock videos
yeah both videos right and it's just
like yeah it's it's it's easy to yeah
kind of get caught up in it emotionally
for sure not not to say that it's wrong
to have an emotional response you should
have an emotional response to that type
of thing that's another fellow human
being who's suffering you know in Japan
injustice right but if you're gonna like
somebody like you who actually has a
platform where a lot of people follow
you right exactly
you gotta take the time to really digest
it and and figure out what it is that
you want to say and how you want to
approach it right so you know it's it's
it's that instant gratification kind of
culture people got mad at me because I
said I mentioned this on the last
podcast there's a this guy Brian Ortega
and slapped jay Park in the face he's a
UC USC fighters oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
remember seeing about yeah yeah podcast
where I was like I wonder what the [ __ ]
you said to him right and like he didn't
say how could you do that how could you
say I'm like I'm saying hypothetical I'm
not saying he did yeah you're saying
that you know usually when somebody gets
slapped yeah probably said some [ __ ] you
know what the whole thing was about
right it was about Korean Zombie yeah it
was like the translation or some [ __ ]
yeah basically he was jay Park being a
fan of the Korean Zombie what like kind
of became his unofficial translator what
a weird yeah right heard segue yeah I
don't know how that happened but so he
was translating for the dude and I guess
Korean zombie was kind of like talking
[ __ ] and then so jay Park translated
that and Brian Ortega took offense to it
as if like Jay Park said it himself and
is like you know next time I see you you
know it's like we're gonna say yeah it's
like why why [ __ ] shoot the messenger
I forgot what the specificity was but I
heard like originally chanson Jung it
wasn't really talking that much [ __ ] he
thought that jay Park embellished it
which he didn't I guess it was like
pretty straight yeah translation yeah
and then he then he slapped him or some
[ __ ] by guess like he said they kind of
squashed it off water or whatever and
then he did another translation where he
was talking [ __ ] but his lily jay Park
is translating what he said no it's like
dude come on man the dude is he's not a
[ __ ] fighter you're a trained fighter
right your hands are considered lethal
weapons right like what are you doing
slapping a civilian okay some even if I
was a lethal fighter if you talking [ __ ]
off the slap use weapons to work and
then when your pregnant wife gives birth
to your child I'll slap that child and
start choking you a little right there
just to teach you a lesson your daddy
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] hell yeah
well hey guys that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast we talked a
little bit about a mod our Barry rest in
peace his family finds peace with all
that other stuff kind of sat on that for
a little bit yeah we went over other
[ __ ] too that everybody's listening
to you by the way Amazon is listening
right now whatever you say to Amazon
they're gonna [ __ ] put that [ __ ] out
and you're gonna buy a Serbian knife
like I'm sure if you guys are watching
this just look a little bit into like
Amazon and tik-tok what type of data
they're they're collecting on you
I'm not saying stop using it I mean I'm
still an Amazon Prime member but at
least just be aware of it you know what
I mean you know what can they find you
you can find me on Instagram ed to EDT
wo that's right well you guys you can
catch us all on Spotify and stitcher and
everything else and Spotify set your
iTunes all that other stuff and I will
see you all next time peace [ __ ]